hello everyone
and
yeah perfect i have control over my
slides
so as i mentioned um i'm going to
discuss
uh understanding of uh deep neural
networks
uh at signify i'm
doing data science and engineering kind
of a mixed profile
and yeah you can read more about it or
connect on linkedin
so at signify we um
putting a lot of emphasis on
sustainability uh this year
we get quite a nice achievement
we are 100 carbon neutral company
i think it's amazing considering all the
climate uh
change uh issues that we are facing
these days
and the growth areas uh for us
is the following so in the climate
action for example we contributing with
the
highly efficient leds and solar energy
in circular economy
it's mostly 3d printing examples
uh we have a horticulture proposition
for the food availability
urban connected lighting for safety and
security
and for the health and well-being i
think that's
something that's really irrelevant these
days it's ubc lighting for disinfection
and we have a smart lighting
for home uh hue ecosystem
and let's say a human-centric lighting
proposition for
uh offices called nature connect quite
amazing thing that
can provide let's say a sky view
for your office um i'm really passionate
about that so
you can imagine that we have quite
amount of uh
different data to work with and
we're doing a lot of modeling and we
also have a lot of stakeholders that
asking a question
and here comes the explanability so why
in general we need explainability tools
so first of all if we take let's say
most critical applications such as
health care self-driving or military
which directly
uh impacting human lives then
the question of how exactly the models
are doing the decision how they're
supporting us
it's quite uh open and
relevant and if we take into account the
majority of the
algorithms that uh behind of this
application this neural networks
and deep neural networks which are uh
treated as a black box
usually uh then it makes even more
important right so
uh we're always raising concerns and
interest about that there's a lot of
discussion
about gender or race bias adversarial
examples that can break
image classification networks and yeah
ruin your self-driving car uh there's
also a lot of uh
ethical concerns and uh in general
whether we can trust the decision right
if you if you get some kind of
diagnosis uh or you your uh
loan application was rejected because of
um
yeah some random forest i don't know
yeah you would like to know why right
it's uh
you would like to know uh particular
explanation for your case and also i
think
another driving factor it's uh curiosity
we are all quite
curious and would like to know how
exactly this complex model
are working and to help
us there's this whole field these days
called
uh explainable ai or xai
uh i personally don't like ai term i
think it's
for uh marketing people but yeah if you
use machine learning it will get xml
make some more confusion okay xai
this tool this field basically allows us
to
uh use some methods and tools and solve
all these
problems with explanations um
yeah let's take step uh back so yeah
well
i'm using logistic regression for
example right i mean it's quite
explainable model why i need all these
tools
indeed there's a set of machine learning
models that
quite explainable however there's a
cases when
on the first glance highly explainable
model may become
way less explainable you can think about
uh
k nearest neighbors classifier right if
your feature space is super small
then well yeah you probably can explain
it but then if you have like i don't
know
thousands of features then probably need
something else
rather than just the plots and another
problem that
we are usually facing is that simple
models uh they perform
poor and you start using some complex
models
but then when you're uh using complex
models uh
they're difficult to explain to your
customers right so
that's kind of a paradox and then you
need these tools again
if you look for the scientific articles
on
explainability uh there's a quiet uh
uh writing trend i would see i would say
uh like a few few days ago actually
there was also another
newspaper released for like that's doing
a lot of overview of these methods
so yeah it's becoming difficult to catch
up with
these things uh but this uh articles
mostly
focused on the following things so a
part of the
new methods uh that are developed
there's also important concept of
notions or
requirements and characteristics that
you would like
to impose on these methods let's say
what in general the question what is the
good explanation for your model
what do you want to have a plot graph
scheme of rules
so i think uh these notions they come a
bit forward and then the methods trying
to satisfy these requirements
and obviously there's a lot of
systematic reviews
and benchmarks of the existing methods
let's deep dive into the methods itself
so
for the methods we have that kind of
taxonomy
um simple simple things
to explain let's say it's uh io input
output and output format it's
mostly standard numerical data textual
time series
and output can be whatever you designed
let's say
it could be mixed output it could be
numerical or rules
uh in terms of the problem type it's
mostly classification or uh
regression in a supervised setting uh
there are some models
and attempts for unsupervised one
but i will not use them in a production
i would say environment it's just still
let's say first attempts
important thing to mention is uh
scope and the stage this is something
that uh really
uh we need to discuss in detail so uh
first i will start with scope it could
be local or
global and the local scope uh method
state trying to
address an individual point of your data
set so let's say bob is coming to the
bank to get the loan and he was refused
by amazing machine learning model that
was deployed
and he's asking why and then that
local methods they can explain why
uh that happened what kind of features
contribute to that
and that's particularly useful when
you're dealing with
separate examples another methods are
global
they mostly giving you an idea of the
whole
model performance based on your based on
the group of
data points and uh yeah they're
generating explanations for that
another thing is the stage when you're
applying these methods so there's
interesting or antihoc methods that they
take explainability in mind a good
example of it could be
that you're optimizing your neural
network not only for your performance
features but for some
explainability metric altogether which
which makes this uh particular methods
less transferable from one particular
model to another
uh but yeah still there's a
quite some chunk of the of these methods
on the graph
and i think the most popular one is post
hoc methods that apply afterwards so you
have your model you would like to
explain something
and this methods they trying to directly
explain your results
or mimic the behavior of your model and
explain the results i think that the
power uh
within like the method that i would like
to use it's probably something that
can explain both local and the global
scope uh
post hoc obviously and
another classification but also present
on the slide it's uh yeah whether it's
model agnostic or model specific
and i would say yeah model agnostic
methods are
more in favor if you are new in this
topic of explainability there's one
particular
method that i would like to recommend if
you're just starting it's called
uh shop it stands for sharply added
explanations and why this method
uh because it's based on the solid
theory so you can actually explain
the results quite good i'm not going to
go into details but
in general it's based on the shapley
values which is the concept from
game theory that allows you to specify
attribution of your features and how the
influencing the model
so another thing this method allows you
to look at the local
scope so this particular graph here
showing that
how the feature driving model
performance from some base value to
particular model output they also have
some methods for uh neural networks
uh mostly visualization-wise
for the gradients you can also see the
global
view of your uh of your features which
i think kind of makes this method is
also global partially
and another nice part is it also
supports
like traditional explainability methods
such as partial dependency plots so it's
also
super useful to see how your model
behaving using this
so you can find it on scotland github
repository so highly recommended to
start with this
now let's go to the explanation
of uh deep neural networks uh
particularly so
for deep neural networks there's a some
taxonomy but it's it's like similar that
what i already said
but i'll just want to go into detail so
there's three main
uh groups of methods first one is the
visualization
and when you basically have your
uh input image let's say and you're
trying to visualize how
predictions of your neural network are
influenced by
by your input so you're trying to
compose some kind of scientific
visualization
for your input this is something that
we're going to
look into detail during tutorial and
another thing is uh distillation
so it's mostly
when you're trying to use some kind of
white box model
to mimic the input output behavior of
your complex neural network
let's say you have decision tree or
uh svm something like that uh decision
tree is more popular i think and then
you're just
getting input inputs and outputs of your
neural network and on these inputs and
outputs you're training your decision
tree and decision tree is explainable
model
so you can use it to facilitate
requirements of your customers and
another thing that i already mentioned
it's interesting one when you
incorporate the optimization of
performance metric and the quality
metric straight away
uh for visualization methods
uh they also ha different in the nature
so a quite extensive classification i
would say
uh first type it's a back propagation
based when you're using a gradient uh
information that uh inside of the
weights of the neural network
to generate this uh visualization
and another one it's a perturbation
based when
you're changing your input usually
occluding it with some kind of kernel on
top
and you trying to estimate like okay uh
how a model performing uh on this
changed input
compared to the original input and
yeah back propagation methods uh
in general i mean this whole idea sounds
for me like this picture
when yeah how we can explain machine
learning
models here we will just use more
machine learning and
we'll be good with that a bit of a
recursion here i think
but yeah a bit of more practical
problems
so this is a really nice example from
the pascal
voc data set the problem here is quite
interesting this data set contains
a lot of picture that was labeled as a
horse
class let's say that particular one
however if you try to visualize
some kind of using one of these methods
uh for visualization
uh where exactly model is looking for
and you will find out that
this heat map is looking on this
watermark and
that's the big problem because if you
remove this watermark and you provide a
picture
that contains the horse you will not get
the prediction of the horse anymore
and even more words that if you add it
to some kind of artificially generated
image
it will predict that as a horse so i
think that this is something something
that needs to be
validated or checked at the stage
of model development so
what i'm going to do i'm going to show
you some
uh methods that can uh you can
incorporate for that
so in order to follow the tutorial you
need to go
in this github link now
click uh for opening uh collapse
page and then uh you will see something
like this
let me see if i can yeah
so in this tutorial we're going to use
um
captum framework which is
by torch-based uh there's also
tensorflow alternative for those who
using tensorflow extensively and i also
put the link for the
algorithms explanations because i cannot
go in detail
or for each of them so yeah what i'm
going
doing here is mostly i'm installing the
this
captain framework and yeah i'm getting
some image in that class
index to just understand uh what kind of
uh classes are there and their mapping
then the downloading some test images
you can then later on
varian pick something else
here standard imports nothing fancy the
most important part i think
it's this one so there are some methods
for
attribution and particularly we focus
on several gradient one and then also
occlusion one
so in terms of preparation uh it's
purely standard thing
so just opening this class index to
understand the
index to labels mapping i'm using it as
net 50 pre-trained on imagenet
uh and then also defining some
transforms
for specifically for this model
resize conversion to tensors
and also normalization uh according to
the imagenet
and uh yeah i'm doing if opening this
amazing picture with the cat that you
saw on the slide
and also uh doing a forward
pass through the neural network and
getting top three predictions so i think
it's quite useful to have
five of them because sometimes uh this
model are not
performing really well so yeah
in our case it's a good and simon's cat
i think it's a
quite uh straightforward example and
easy to understand
and there's some visualization function
that based on the
uh captain as well i just put some
parameters
uh to simplify the code a bit so the
first uh
group of methods as i mentioned is the
propagation ones
and the simple thing that you can do is
just uh return the gradient
of uh your output with respect to the
input it's a
quite noisy uh approach i would say that
you can see here that i'm doing that so
initializing the silency model and then
it
goes directly just providing the your
input predicting
uh label index that you want that uh for
which you want to find the attribution
and the visualization to the other
things so even though you may say that
this heat map is quite good
because yeah it's kind of like a contour
of the cat and
masking material looks really well but
it's quite noisy
in the nature so there's silency maps
was introduced quite a long time ago
another method called input times
gradient
this one is an extension of silency
approach
what it's doing is that the same thing
gradient of the
output with respect to input but also
you're multiplying by the input features
and it's a bit better so you see that
it's less
noisy still have a contour of the of the
cat
uh yeah keep in mind again that this
picture is uh
yeah far from the real use cases because
this background is almost the same so
it's not surprisingly performing that
good
um another method called guided back
propagation
so this is a bit again extension of
silency maps i would say
uh here you're just imposing some rule
on
review activation function so it's only
a
backpacker gate no negative gradients so
and here you can see that it's getting
like
uh a bit a bit better results
so uh it's really now
uh showing the features that okay why
this cat
is a is that type same as cat why is
that so
it's really focusing on the head of the
cat and
another one uh called uh guided grad cam
uh another extension of the method which
is now
focusing not only i think i supposed to
have a picture here but
uh yeah probably it's uh get lost
somewhere
on the way um on github there should be
a picture there
so um the thing is that this method
is uh looking also uh
to the gradient of the output with
respect to some
internal layers of your network so here
you can see that i'm providing like a
layer four it's like in the resonant 50
the latest group of
uh convolutions and uh together with
this
uh particular um feature maps
it's also using a guided back
propagation
altogether up sampling the results and
getting even better
results so if you take this images and
zoom in
compare that one with this one this is
the less noisy
so what you can do at this point in time
if you're training near
let's say object detection image
classification models
uh you can just incorporate this uh
image generation on your typical
training cycle right so you can just use
it
by the end of each epoch uh generating
these pictures just
to see where the model is looking at uh
you'll be so
surprised sometimes uh another group
of methods because for some people uh
call this
uh tricks with the gradient sounds a bit
like uh
well i need something i need something
more
uh solid or something less connected to
gradients because it's uh
kind of like sounds not that stable and
not that robust
you can try perturbation based methods
this one
actually a nice alternative so i
suggest you also to use it let's say
together with the
back propagation one and what the core
idea as i already mentioned
you just including your for example
in particular in occlusion model you're
including your
input with um with some kind of kernel
uh with a sliding window here i'm using
60 by 60 sliding window with some stride
and it will generate predictions for
each of the
uh occlusion examples and then compare
it with the baseline to see let's say
which particular one are really
affecting the score
and you can get the let's say example
like this
it can be tunable and yeah used uh
also in the training cycle as well so
[Music]
this is kind of the basics i would say
that you can get from this tutorial
i also include here at the beginning
some other methods like
feature ablation and feature permutation
i suggest you to take a look
at the captain's library and to see how
this method scan
suits you so let's go back to the
slides um
yeah so that's basically it so just few
words about references right so when
you're faced in a situation where you
need to explain your models and
uh uh given an idea let's say on some
like
basic level i would say that you can try
sharp
and use it uh let's say
if you're deep in the computer vision uh
researcher industrial research whatever
i highly recommend to look at
two recent cdpr and iccb
workshop sections they have quite nice
perturbation based
models that can even help you to
identify adversarial examples so that's
something that uh
i'm currently exploring and using it's
uh amazing i
put the links on this uh slide
i will also share it afterwards and yeah
if
you can also read systematic reviews
they produce almost every month and
they always like update it and i think
it's quite nice if you just would like
to see the whole field
and you don't know what uh what kind of
models are there and stuff like that
uh and there's also some practical
examples for
tensorflow and yeah you can use capture
move using pytorch
so that's more or less it i hope that
this talk will make your models more
explainable to your stakeholders
and i'm happy to answer your questions
awesome talk thanks a lot vladimir and i
see this topic being more and more and
more important
on every conference i'm attending
so thanks for addressing this we do have
questions and uh
first thing is do you have methods that
also work well for one-dimensional data
and for example time series data uh
i think uh there's um let's say
uh model agnostic methods uh
that can be applied also to the time
series data as well
i personally uh didn't use it myself
but there is an implementation four time
series data as well
right and i have a question myself um
when i look at model explainability for
me there are two side of things one is
that when you are
evaluating the model on your notebook
and then also
another phase when you go into an
operational mode
do you have any uh like advisor
specialized tool that looks into that
because the model
is changing if you have for example
continuous training enabled
how do you deal with that right now
well i would say that uh there's a
standard monitoring tools
right for for the machine learning model
in production
so uh you can of course
uh incorporate one of these
explainability tools as a part of this
monitoring tools
let's say and just monitor it as any
normal any other metric right so if you
get an adversarial example
uh for your image classification model
uh you can monitor the masks
uh of one of the method that i mentioned
previously and you see if something
changed
then that's the signal but i think it
varies from uh
let's say uh field to field right so
it's different for
nlp it's also different for computer
vision so it's like
i don't know the particular uh names
that can be
uh directly plugged in into production
setting
uh but i think like this general uh
frameworks for tensorflow and pythons
that provide explainability can be
incorporated quite easily
so it's the same code base right
and we have another question on discord
uh from one
uh how do you explain the stake to the
stakeholder what is the shop
value uh well i can use this uh
amazing example with the picture of uh
with the pile of money
and then uh go with whole explanation
like how you will
split this money between the
participants i think this analogy will
work
quite well for product owners and
stakeholders
so right well we have a comment on that
it's like
red push up and blue push down
so cool and um yeah
engage on discord and also
i know you already shared your links for
the code base over there but i also
encourage that in this if you have some
time
uh check out vladimir's notebook and
give it a go
you